اصدرت الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
القرار
181 القاضي بتقسيم فلسطين ومع انسحاب
القوات البريطانيه وضعت القدس تحت الوصايه
الدوليه خلال حرب عام 48 احتلت العصابات
الصهيونيه الجزء الغربي من مدينه القدس
متوقفه عند سور البلده القديمه وفي حرب
حزيران 67 احتل الجيش الاسرائيلي الضفه
الغربيه بما فيها الشطر الشرقي من القدس
وحياء الشيخ جراح ووادي الجوز وما بين
الاعوام السبعه 67
صدرت مجموعه من القرارات الدوليه التي
تؤكد ان قطاع غزه والضفه الغربيه بما فيها
شرقي القدس هي اراضي محتله عام 80 اقر
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي مشروعا قضى بان القدس
الموحده بشطريها هي عاصمه اسرائيل
رفضه المجتمع الدولي واعتبره غير قانوني
وعلى الرغم من ذهاب الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين الى جولات تفاوض على اساس
حل الدولتين بقيت مدينه القدس بشقيها الى
جانب الاستيطان والحدود خارج اطار
الاتفاقيات الرسميه لاسيما اتفاقيه اوسلو
عام 93
واشلت الى ما سميت مفاوضات الحل النهائي
وخلال توقيع على الاتفاقيه ضمه اسرائيل
عددا من المستوطنات الى حدود المدينه
الاداريه
وكانت اتفاقيه اوسلو الانتقاليه قد قسمت
اراضي الضفه الغربيه الى ثلاث مناطق منطقه
الف تخضع امنيا واداريا بالكامل للسلطه
الفلسطينيه منطقه باء تخضع اداريا للسلطه
الفلسطينيه وامنيا لاسرائيل ومنطقه جيم
تخضع امنيا واداريا بالكامل للسيطره
الاسرائيليه وبقيت السيطره الامنيه
الاسرائيليه كامله على مدينه القدس
بشطريها عام 2002 بدات اسرائيل بناء جدار
عازل اقتطعت بموجبه مزيدا من اراضي الضفه
الغربيه وبشكل مفاجئ عام 2017 اعترف
الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب بالقدس
عاصمه لاسرائيل ونقل اليها السفاره
الامريكيه
وفيما سميت مبادره صفقه القرن عرضت على
الفلسطينيين ان تكون عاصمتهم ابوديس وهي
بلده وقيعه شرقي القدس وفي محاوله لربط
المستوطنات وفصل شمال الضفه عن جنوبها وعن
القدس عملت حكومات اسرائيل على ضم اجزاء
من الضفه الغربيه مثل الخان الاحمر الى
الحدود الاداريه لمدينه القدس
[موسيقى]